la dernière fois je vous ai posé le
défilé 3 qui posait la question suivante
deux étoiles tournait autour de l'autre
une étoile explose que se passe-t-il je
vous invite à mettre pause et à y
réfléchir voire à fermer cette fenêtre
et prendre vraiment le temps de la
réflexion pendant un jour ou deux puis
regardez cette vidéo ensuite
alors je vous avais bien dit de traiter
la question dans le cadre de la théorie
newtonienne mais il ya quand même des
petits malins parmi vous comme tic al
iman mofaz camille marjorie et jesse et
chapi chapo qui ont sorti un argument
relativiste en disant que rien ne peut
aller plus vite que la lumière
du coup si une des deux étoiles
disparaît alors l'autre ne le saura pas
tout de suite je sais d'où vient cette
idée c'est une vulgarisation extrêmement
classique consiste à faire cette
expérience de pensée sur laquelle le
soleil disparaît à ce que la terre est
affecté par ce changement immédiatement
brian greene utilisent d'ailleurs cette
image dans des gunners pour justifier le
fait que la théorie de newton est
incomplète et qu'il fallait une nouvelle
théorie de la gravité sauf que c'est
faux et oui on est parti pour un énième
des bonnes king d'une vulgarisation
classique de la relativité générale
le problème de base c'est que la
conservation de l'énergie en tout point
de l'espace temps et quelque chose donc
audet fondamentalement dans l'équation
d'einstein vous souvenez vous avez dit
très rapidement sous longtemps par là
c'est que les combinaisons linéaire du
tenseur d'hansson une tonsure métriques
sont les seuls temps soeur de valence 2
feuilles de dérivés opus secondes du
temps sur mes tricks à être de quadri
divergences nu en particulier ce que ça
veut dire c'est que vous aussi vous
imaginez que le temps passe vers le haut
et que et de l'énergie qui arrive en un
point de l'espace tort et voit cet
énergique doit ressortir de vers le
futur donc les conservations locale de
l'énergie est encodé fondamentalement
dans les équations d'einstein
du coup il est impossible de faire
disparaître le soleil d'un coup de
baguette magique
donc là je parle d'énergie mais la
matière la matière celle uniquement une
concentration d'énergie comme j'en ai
parlé dans l'épisode 6 et en fait ce qui
se passe c'est aussi une étoile explose
ben la matière qui s'en va de cette
étoile ne peut s'en aller qu'à la
vitesse de la lumière au maximum et en
fait ce n'est qu'au moment que cette
matière qui s'en va de l'étoile ces
débris de l'étoile ce n'est qu'au moment
où ces débris atteignent la terre et la
dépasse que la courbure de l'espace
temps au niveau de la terre va être
modifiée lors derrière ce que je veux
dire en fait il est le clone de gauche
henri iv
un équivalent relativiste qui est le
théorème de birkhoff qui dit que la
force de gravité ou la courbure de
l'espace temps en 1 point dans une
symétrie sphérique n'est déterminé que
par la quantité de matière à l'intérieur
de la boule de la maîtrise pierrick qui
est atteint le niveau de la terre donc
temps que cette matière là de l'étoile
n'a pas dépassé la terre la terre ne
sait rien d'eux ne sent rien ça que ce
soit en terme de force de chant de
présenter ou en termes de conduire de
l'esp restant juste pour enfoncer le
clou
je vous rappelle aussi que dans la
théorie d'einstein yen et il ya un
équivalent du citoyen qui est plus
difficile à expliquer pour l'udc ou le
fait localement au niveau de la terre
que l'étoile exploser ou non ne changera
rien à la direction comprenant un espace
temps puisque de toute façon on va tout
droit
ainsi ce dont j'avais pas mal parlé dans
les commentaires de l'épisode 17 que je
vous invite à revoir
bref avancions dans les commentaires et
passons aux commentaires de tomates
rouges qui vous amène dans le domaine de
l'astrophysique en nous faisant
remarquer que l'école qui explose
deviendra une supergéante oui enfin oui
pour notre soleil ça dépend de la taille
de l'étoile comme explique très bien
sébastien carassou dans ce super épisode
de senso brender le soleil dans 5
milliards d'années a grossi avec
grossier à devenir une géante rouge
carbonera d'ailleurs la terre et puis
ensuite dans 8 milliards d'années de
cela il va exploser en une nébuleuse
planétaire en laissant derrière elle un
cadavre des toiles que l'on appelle une
naine blanche
mais allez voir la vidéo de sense of
wonder ils expliquent beaucoup mieux que
ce que je ne pourrai alors ça c'est pour
le soleil mais j'ai rien dit sur les
étoiles en question et ce taux aurait
très bien pu être un autre type des
toiles beaucoup plus massive par exemple
le soleil et si l'étoile en question est
dix fois plus massive que le soleil elle
ferait vraiment une super explosion
qu'on appelle une supernova et ça ça
tombe bien puisque c'est le deuxième
épisode du cnca wonder
dans ce cas la matière va aller très
très vite s'éloigner de l'étoile vitesse
très proche de celle de la lumière
et encore une fois il va rester un
cadavre après cette explosion qui peut
être soit une étoile à neutrons soit un
trou noir par des trucs ultra dense nous
ignorons les débris de l'explosion de
l'étoile
c'est la question qu'ont choisi
d'adresser équinoxe clark le double
et pierre lacombe alors qu'ils n'ont
exclu qu'à essayer de distinguer
différentes violence de l'explosion
d'une étoile alors c'était bien vu
sauf que cinétoile explose ce sera
forcément violent plus tout ira vraiment
à des vitesses très proche de la lumière
en gros ça va être en ébullition notaire
ou un super nova donc et dans ce cas du
coup il ya forte apparaît que la plupart
de la matière va juste silwan y est très
très très vite à une vitesse proche de
celle de la lumière et échapper aux
chars de pesanteur des deux étoiles
le double a quand même essayé de traiter
des débris qui resteraient à d'entre eux
entrer des étoiles qui n'iraient pas du
coup à des vitesses proches de celle de
la lumière
et là on tombe sur un problème difficile
comme l'a très bien souligné le double
puisque on tombe sur le prime fameux des
trois corps gros newton qu'on a
développé ses équations de la théorie de
la gravitation
il y à commencer à résoudre le problème
de deux planètes qui tournent l'une
autour de l'autre ça il savait faire
mais quand il mettait une troisième
planète dans le truc moi il y avait plus
à donner les équations incroyablement
des cuisines si difficile que newton a
levé les mains en l'air puis par terre
et ses 10 ans morte elle ne peut pas
résoudre de tels équation seul dieu peut
le faire et donc dieu existe alors
aujourd'hui les scientifiques rejette
cet argument comme une preuve de
l'existence de dieu
évidemment mais on n'a pas résolu le
prennent des trois corps on pense qu'en
fait il on ne peut pas le résoudre de
façon satisfaisante
ceci dit énormément de progrès qui ont
été faits depuis newton et des gens
comme la place poincaré kolmogorov ou
encore un certain cédric villani
mais comme vous l'imaginez là on rentre
vraiment dans les trucs super compliqué
qui dépasse de loin ce que j'attends de
vous ou de moi dans un défilé jeu quand
même souligner rapidement les
conclusions de tous ses travaux sur la
stabilité des systèmes non seulement à
trois corps mais a plus de corps comme
par exemple le système solaire est ce
que le système solaire va rester stable
ou est ce qu'il est possible qu'une
planète finissent par exemple emporté
par la gravité de jupiter par être
expulsé du système solaire des experts
pensent que ce ne soit pas très probable
dans le milliard d'années qui vont venir
jusqu'au moment de l'explosion du soleil
pour quelques milliards d'années c'est
pas possible
mais en fait il est assez probable
crédible imaginez
une planète avaient déjà été expulsés de
notre système solaire et ça ça répond à
une question de jonathan claptien ce qui
est possible qu'une planète sortent d'un
système solaire oui c'est possible mais
pour aujourd'hui on va faire simple et
on va un peu complètement négligé tous
les débris est supposé que j'étais
l'explosion les débris sont partis tout
serein fini que toute cette masse est
perdue puis d' du coup de notre système
binaire restants et ça c'est vraiment la
question que l'examinateur voulait que
je me pose quand il m'a posé cette
question à l'examen oral en gros il ya
deux réponses possibles soit l'étoile et
le cadavre d'autres étoiles continuent
arbitres et l'une autour de l'autre
soit ils se disent bail et ils s'en vont
s'éloigner jusqu'à l'infini et là d'un
côté fodda legrand et le double semblent
penser que les étoiles vont continuer à
habiter par chrono rif et enguerrand de
gentilles eux pensent qu'à s'éloigneront
à l'infini alors qui a raison
eh bien là c'est le moment il va falloir
que je vous parle de didier mazal qui
est le grand vainqueur de ce défi lé
même s'il n'a pas adressé la question
que je voulais que vous aller l'essayer
l'idée c'est qu'elle me posais une
question intéressante
il y a répondu et puis surtout il a
corroboré ces affirmations par de
merveilleux simulation et la remarque
que voulait faire didier c'est que le
système binaire va se mettre en
mouvement après l'explosion de l'étoile
c'est assez cool est surprenant c'est
papa si intuitif
si une des deux étoiles explose dans le
système binaire alors les deux étoiles
le cadavre restants et puis l'autre
étoile vont se mettre à se mouvoir dans
une direction qui va être opposé à la
direction du mouvement de l'étoile qui a
explosé au moment où elles explosaient
éviter c'est que l'étoile qui n'a pas
explosé
ben va avoir beaucoup moins de force de
gravité tout à coup sûr elle du coup il
ya moins de force qui perturbe son
mouvement du coup elle va aller en haut
tout droit et puis le cadavre lui va
continuer à être emporté par cette
étoile et du coup ça va partir et le
plus génial c'est que son intuition est
parfaitement corroborée par les
simulations telles qu'il les a fait
aimer les a on voyait tout fait
apprécier ces images ont été faites avec
le logiciel universe sandbox
ce projet
j'étais heureuse c'est trop trop trop
beau
avant l'explosion on a un système
binaire avec ses deux étoiles qui nous
tourner l'une autour de l'autre
ou plus exactement vont tourner s'ils
ont des trajectoires elliptique dans le
référentiel de centre de masse et où le
centre de masse va être un foyer de ses
ellipses ça c'est un exercice classique
de physique en études supérieures et je
vous ai mis tous les détails des calculs
sur mon blog est en gros pour résoudre
ce problème vous avez besoin de trois
quantité conserver suffit d'invoquer la
conservation du camp de la quantité de
mouvement la conservation de l'énergie
et la conservation du moment angulaire
et après vous habituer ses calculs et
vous devrez trouver de bons résultats
plus ou moins quelques astuces trait à
la newton et là j'en profite pour ouvrir
une petite parenthèse relativiste si à
la place des deux étoiles assez
éloignées l'une de l'autre
on avait deux trous noirs de truc ou
deux étoiles à neutrons qui tournait à
ses proches l'une de l'autre
à ce moment là les équations de la
relativité générale ferait des
prédictions distincte de celle de la
théorie newtonienne il me dirait que ces
trous noirs se rapprocherait lui l'un de
l'autre en émettant des ondes
gravitationnelles
et ce sont de ces raisons de
gravitationnelle là que par le fluence
parcelles et david lowe âpre puisque ces
zones gravitationnelle ont récemment été
détecté en février dernier et il s'agit
d'une énième réfutation de la théorie du
thonier fin de la parenthèse relativiste
essayons de calcul maintenant la vitesse
du système binaire après l'explosion
qu'est la vitesse qui prennent tout d'un
coup alors pour cela on va invoquer la
conservation du goût de la quantité de
mouvement donc si on appelle m1 et m2
les masses des deux étoiles j'ai appelé
alpha la proportion de la masse conservé
par le cadavre et je vais appeler vers
la vitesse du cadavre au moment de
l'explosion
alors vous pour simplifier j'ai supposé
que l'explosion de l'étoile en supernova
être parfaitement symétrique
bon c'est pas le cas et en fait c'est
assez c'est très difficile c'est un
poème de recherche actuelle de savoir
comment calculer ou anticipés ou prédire
ou de comprendre modéliser l'explosion
d'une étoile en supernova mais j'ai eu
l'autorisation de sébastien carrasso
de supposées en première approximation
que le lait supernova a été parfaitement
symétrique du coup la vitesse moyenne
des débris va être la même que la
vitesse de l'étoile moment de son
explosion est la quantité de masse de
ces débris total veut être tout ce qui a
été perdu c'est à dire 1 - alpha fois m
1 du coup la quantité de mouvement
emporté par les débris va être un -
alpha m 1 v1
or la quantité de mouvements du système
binaire après explosion ça va être la
masse système binaire après explosion
c'est-à-dire alpha et main pucelle deux
fois la vitesse du système binaire vous
appelez savez j'ai projets pour son de
gravité et la conservation de la
quantité de mouvement me dis que ces
deux entités doivent annuler et du coup
elles sont égales et en particulier vga
est égale 1 - alpha fois m 1 / alpha et
main puis cm2 autrement dit ce qui fait
que votre système binaire va prendre
beaucoup de vitesse c'est un le fait que
les étoiles tournait déjà très vite
avant l'explosion en particulier les
toits l'un d'eux alpha est petit c'est à
dire la proportion de masse conservé par
le cadavre est très petit
en gros elle perd quasi totalité de sa
masse et 3 le fait que l' étoile qui
explose à une masse beaucoup plus grande
que la masse de l'autre étoile tout ça
c'est déjà super cool mais ça répond pas
à la question qui m'avait été posées ou
plutôt que l'examinateur cet oral de
l'ena
vous voulez que je me pose à savoir est
ce que le système binaire va rester en
orbite bien dans la simulation d'un
didier on voit que dans son cas oui les
étoiles restent en orbite l'une autour
de l'autre ce qui est vachement jolie je
trouve ça vraiment cool mais ce n'est
qu'une simulation dans un cas
particulier est ce que ce sera tout le
temps le cas
et du coup une fois que j'ai vu ces
images que j'avais ces questions en tête
je me suis bien sûr précipiter sur
didier je me suis mis à le harceler pour
qu'il me soit d'autres images dans
d'autres cas pour voir si c'est des
étoiles pouvait se séparer infinie et on
a vu que oui d'autres simulations les
deux étoiles s'éloigner à l'infini mais
du coup la question importante c'est de
savoir qu'est ce qui va déterminer sa
part ce qui est vraiment cool c'est que
la réponse peut être déterminée par un
unique calcul celui de l'énergie alors
l'énergie totale d'un système binaire
ça va être l'énergie cinétique de la
première étoile 1/2
m 1 v1 au carré si on regarde après
l'explosion la masse de la première
étoile qui va être plutôt son cadavre
ça va être alfheim plus l'énergie
cinétique de la deuxième étoile qui perd
un demi de m2 v2 au carré plus l'énergie
potentielle de gravitation cette énergie
qu'il vit les deux étoiles en trail ça
c'est égal à - 1 g al fahem rennes 2 /
la distance entre les deux que je vais
appeler m alors ça c'est l'énergie
totale du système dont le référentiel du
centre de masse avant explosion
on a vu que le système binaire prenez
une vitesse après explosion du coût en
fait pour vraiment calculer l'énergie
qui va être pertinente l'année est ce
qu'on va faire
il faut en fait calculés l'énergie du
système dans le référentiel du centre de
masse
après explosion et ça pour ça il suffit
en fait de modifier un peu cette
équation est rajouté des thermes ont
veillé au bon endroit où vais-je et
c'était à vitesse du système binaire et
là on a une expression de l'énergie
totale du système dans son référentiel
de centre de masse est alors pourquoi
est-ce que le calcul l'énergie va nous
permettre de déterminer si oui ou non
les étoiles s'en vont à l'infini ou pas
bien ça vient du fait que l'énergie
cinétique est forcément toujours
positive du coup si l'énergie totale du
système est négative il y aura toujours
ce terme de gravité qui devra être
important il devra toujours avoir une
valeur importante ce qui veut dire que
la distance entre les deux étoiles ne
peut pas grandir à l'infini autrement
dit si l'énergie totale du système
binaire dans son référentiel centre de
masse est négative alors les deux
étoiles vont rester en orbite l'une
autour de l'autre inverse si cette
quantité est positive c'est à dire que
l'énergie cinétique domine l'énergie
potentielle de pesanteur et du coup les
deux étoiles vont avoir tellement
d'énergie cinétique elles vont
s'éloigner et du coup si cette énergie
est en fait supérieur ou égal à zéro
alors les deux étoiles vont s'éloigner à
l'infini alors cette formule de
l'énergie écrivent comme ça et pas très
parlante difficile de l'interpréter du
coup il faut un peu la travailler pour
faire dire des trucs un peu plus
compréhensible donc encore une fois j'ai
fait tous les calculs sur mon blog je
vais pas vous laisser expliqué dans
cette vidéo mais j'obtiens après
de longs calculs l'expression suivante
toute l'énergie après explosion dans un
référentiel de centre de masse du
système binaire après explosion s'était
gala alpha fois l'énergie du système
binaire avant explosion d'un référentiel
de somme de massa bre explosions plus un
terme un peu compliqué ici dont on va
pas mal par les oies alpha fois
l'énergie cinétique du système binaire
avant l'explosion et dans le référentiel
de bath avant explosion
donc comme je l'aï dit la destinée des
deux étoiles l'une par rapport à l'autre
va dépendre du cygne de cette expression
est donc les étoiles restent proches
l'une de l'autre si et seulement si un -
alpha fois m
1 / alfheim un pli sem deux fois
l'énergie cinétique avant est inférieure
à l'opposé de l'énergie avant explosion
toute l'énergie avant l'explosion comme
les étoiles tournait bien l'une autour
de l'autre elle est forcément négatif du
coup là on a bien un terme positives à
droite et donc la réponse va dépendre
allemand de cette quantité à gauche ici
on peut donc là la réinterpréter et
conclure que les étoiles vont rester
proche une autour de l'autre si
premièrement elle était déjà
suffisamment en orbite l'une autour de
l'autre c'est à dire que l'énergie
initiale le terme de droite était déjà
très négatif composantes de la pesanteur
était très grande
deuxièmement la fraction de masse
conserver alpha est grande pour s'en
convaincre il suffit de regarder le cas
limite si alpha est égal à 1 c'est à
dire en fait qu'il ya eu d'explosion du
coup comme les plastiques a pas
d'explosion
l'étoile tournait déjà avant elles
tourneront encore après si alpha est
égal à zéro inverse faut imaginer qu'à
ce moment là y'a plus de force de
gravité entre les deux du coup s'il ya
plus de force de gravité bas elles
s'éloigneront à l'infini troisièmement
les toiles qui explosent à une masse
faible par rapport à l'autre étoile
et quatrièmement les étoiles n'allait
pas vite au moment de l'explosion et la
grâce à didier on va pouvoir visualiser
tout ça en particulier les points 3 4
qui sont peut-être plus difficile à
comprendre
alors dans après la vidéo que vous avez
montré tout à l'heure on avait pris
alpha à peu près égale à 10% c'est à
dire que 90% hamas est perdu
comme ça et c'est à peu près la même
masse et on a vu qu'il restait en orbite
du coup j'ai demandé de regarder ce qui
se passe si la masse de l'étoile qui a
explosé tout à coup beaucoup plus grand
et donc la prédictions théoriques les
dix que les étoiles devrait s'éloigner à
l'infini regardant la vidéo est bien
dans la vidéo les deux étoiles avant en
effet s'éloigner à l'infini la
prédiction 3 est confirmé
e
enfin pour tester la prédiction 4 ce
qu'on a fait c'est qu'on a choisi des
orbites qui a été vachement pas
circulaire des orbites assez elliptique
et on a choisi de faire exploser les
étoiles à un moment où on était proches
l'une de l'autre
donc à l'heure périhélie périhélie les
planètes vont très vite a du coup
d'après la prédiction de quatre elles
ont plus de chance de s'éloigner à
l'infini l'énergie cinétique à ce moment
là est vraiment très très grande
donc le terme de gauche est beaucoup
plus important ils ont qu'à ce moment en
effet les étoiles vont à l'infini
il ya un verre sont attestés l'autre cas
où l'étoile qui explosent et exposé au
moment où elle est le plus long c'est à
dire la féline et sur cette simulation
dont voix qui à ce moment là les étoiles
restent proches nos jours de l'autre
donc la prédiction 4 est confirmée
moi je trouve ça juste trop trop beau
m
sérieux pour un théoricien c'est
vraiment le kiff quand vous faites une
prédiction de théorique après de longs
calculs par ces quelques principes
fondamentaux très simple en conservation
à côté de mouvements conservation de
l'énergie et plus vos vidéos et vos
équation fait plein de calculs enfin
sera rapidement on est plus sur des
calculs on pense avoir fait une faute
pour ce qu'on passe constamment avoir
fait des fautes
du coup on arrive à une prédiction mais
on pas 100% sûr de cette prédiction et
du coup on va le tester avec des
expériences et et/ou des simulations et
quand on voit qu elles sont confirmées
comme ça par l'observation production il
ya un sentiment de devoir accompli de
deux choses c'est juste tellement beau
que si on attribue les destructions
feuille de papier
on a fait une prédiction et puis en fait
c'est la réalité c'est très surprenant
et c'est tellement beau que donc merci
merci merci beaucoup didier pour ces
images fantastiques et puis généralement
on voit tout l'intérêt de combiner la
théorie et les simulations ou les
expériences à ce que la théorie c'est un
truc très abstraite il très difficile on
est obligé de simplifier énormément le
monde on fait beaucoup d'hypothèses
simplificatrice et du coup on en tire
des conclusions des prédictions qui sont
très très clairs très très précise mais
qui sont peut-être trop loin d'une vraie
réalité c'est qu'on n'est jamais 100%
sûr de l'accord y est c'est important du
coût de la confirmer par des six nations
par des expériences l inverse quand on
fait des expériences au des simulations
on peut étudier des domaines que la
théorie a du mal à étudier qu'est ce que
c'est de mettre compliqué mais le
problème des simulations c'est que c'est
souvent des expériences c'est à dire
c'est des cas précis c'est difficile à
généraliser quoi alors qu'une théorie et
c'est très très générale pressés et les
deux vont vraiment ensemble pour
vraiment comprendre les sciences et
j'espère que vous avez senti ce bonheur
d'échanger entre la théorie et ici la
simulation et la manière dont cette
combinaison est incroyablement utile
pour faire avancer les sciences en
général donc encore une fois merci merci
beaucoup didier et puis merci à vous et
à tous vos commentaires qui n'ont pas
mal remuer
linge je me suis replongé dans toute
cette physique deuxième année de prépa
sadate
mais c'était vraiment cool de méreau
plonger dedans merci beaucoup merci à la
base je vous ai posé ce problème c'est
pas si innocente ce raisonnement sur
l'énergie est en fait très très
similaire à celui de friedman pour
déterminer la destinée de l'univers dont
je vous ai parlé dans l'épisode de lundi
l'épisode de 21 en particulier vous avez
montré cette équation là qu'on appelle
la première équation de fruit d'une
bonne et on peut la réarrangé et là je
vais écrire en dessous l'équation de
l'énergie totale un système binaire par
exemple là vous remarqué qu'il ya quand
même pas mal de similarités entre les
deux où la taille de l'univers à doter
est remplacé par la distance entre les
deux étoiles
or dans le cas dans le deuxième cas le
cap en étudiant cette vidéo on a su
déterminer la destinée des deux étoiles
par le signe de cette expression de
l'énergie dans le cas de friedman avait
quoi sont appliqués à tout l'univers
entier avec les équations de la
relativité générale d'einstein et bien
la destinée de l'univers est encore
déterminé par le terme de droite et mais
le terme de droite cette fois ce n'est
pas une énergie
c'est une courbure de l'espace donc
c'est vraiment une vision a fait que ces
deux équations en fait son immeuble de
produits mathématiques et du coup les
mathématiques derrière les destinées de
deux étoiles dont l'une a explosé ou la
destinée de l'univers tout entier je
vais finalement ça à peu près les modes
mathématiques
waouh c'est tellement plus complexe que
ce que je comptais faire je vous
remercie c'est grâce à vos commentaires
qui ont été passionnantes passons
maintenant des filets 4 qui va rebondir
sur le commentaire de pixels le 29 34 la
question est la suivante je prends une
bouteille d'eau je vais dans un avion à
jfk ou telle audio aux donations
où va l'eau est ce que l'on reste en bas
c'est la question à laquelle j'aimerais
que vous réfléchissez et vous pouvez
obliger les frottement de l'air si vous
voulez mais vous pouvez aussi ça va tu
as mal d'avoir la réponse s'il y a des
frottements des revoir des courants
d'air parce que l'eau reste alors en bas
puis question même bonus imaginer que je
mets un petit ballon d'hélium aussi à
l'intérieur de cette bouteille je clique
ici au sol le ballon d'hélium du coup
monté ayrault
est ce que ce sera encore le cas quand
la bouteille de chute libre et qu' au
règlement allez je vous laisse réfléchir
à tout ça partager la vidéo ce que vous
avez aimé et mettez toutes vos idées de
réponse dans les commentaires
après quelques dernières convulsions le
soleil va finir par éjecter ses proches
de dexter nommé un grandiose ce
phénomène la paix la phase deux
niveleuses planétaire